Oh God rats
buddy it's purified and welcome to wrap
the [ __ ] are you doing
it's [ __ ] Saturday not Friday you
know
you know I press Ed's Saturday Fridays
would pay to pie a little history lesson
for you brothers today I started this
maybe over a little over a year ago
because when I play video games
I feel like yes it's fun but it doesn't
this doesn't give me any chance to
connect with you bro so basically every
week I'm like what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do for Friday and I'm always
like ah Friday's coming and then
eventually I just ran out of [ __ ]
time to do something so my apologies
bros I'm eating this by the way Swedish
bizarre
have you ever tried this hi hey try try
one is it good
ok so we're gonna have a QA I asked you
bros on Facebook you can ask me whatever
you want
isn't that cool I like to see hiking and
what's your favorite sandwich the one
that your mama make so what's your
favorite video game character ah show
Minami moto I think it's called it's a
character from The World Ends With You
it's really funny so damn slow so zetta
slow Joel Sebastian Isaac do you know
that Argentina lobster I want to know
where that better that makes me happy I
remember when we studied countries in
South Africa which I chose Argentina oh
yeah
special bond going out muddy hog about
it yet why do you call yourself paid by
it's a long story it's based on
different events basically I just put
pew from lasers rip you and I together
and we have to die and then I forgot my
password to my peuta I account so I
added PI because I usually say beer back
when I was playing video games as a fun
thing and people thought it was funny
and could just kind of catch Donna my
dears ignite somebody [ __ ] question
well you have some wedding [ __ ]
question time or you want from me
I'm sorry sorry come on y'all
why are you so dang funny man I don't
really think I'm that funny I just think
I'm selling stupid I think most of you
bros will agree on that
scarlet bill how are you allowed to use
music in your videos every so many other
youtubers come to me and like what is he
doing he can't put music in his video
you can't I'm a I'm an idiot
I couldn't get copyright problems but so
far I haven't got any copyright problems
the only time I owned I had a problem
with YouTube is that when I uploaded the
heavy rain scene when Madison strips I
got in trouble on that one but otherwise
I didn't really have a troll problem so
I guess I'm lucky
Francie's Lee Arnold what is the worst
game you have ever played I'll show ya
this piece of [ __ ] right here
I thought it saw and I was like ah I
might as well buy the used one because
this game looks really shitty and guess
what and [ __ ] it and I love you
brother like you have to play it you
have to play it and I'm like I'm not
playing this [ __ ] you know what it's
really really really really [ __ ]
terrible it's your real name and age
well my name real name is Felix
Kjellberg but in Sweden we have two
names extra like a middle name and an
extra name I think it's pretty common in
Europe but my girlfriend thing is really
funny that I have it because they don't
have it in Italy
so I go by Felix Arvid Ulf shuttlebay
that's my name that's my [ __ ]
name morning Moises on is what's your
favorite childhood movie Clockwork
Orange
it's great for kids and watch Dora bar
when are you going to do another Walking
Dead Oh Andrew you are I'm sorry
Oh Andrew Zahra why you are just playing
silly ever since I started playing
Walking Dead people realize that they
are released over time I can't play
something that's not out yet I can't do
it I can't play something dead sorry I
mean I mean Andrew you are silly it's
not out yet ah next question Christopher
Deacon have you ever told someone
do you remember Susan Boyle I wrote
something about her as a joke the people
people took it pretty bad and the one
who owned the account for America's
[ __ ] what is it called Britain's Got
Talent
channel even contacted me and they wrote
how stupid I am I thought it was
hilarious at the time but you know it's
good fun I know I have a ton of [ __ ]
crawl to my channel and I don't care
about the trolls what I care about is
when people answer them and he's like ah
it's obvious it's a troll why do you
even bother it's like I don't even know
and a POW comb how was you and Martha's
first kiss ah
what's funny about me and mud say is
that since we met online you know you
can't chest online through so that's
really weird when you meet someone that
you feel something for for the first
time even though you haven't met them in
person I know a lot of people probably
could can find that hard to believe but
we weren't really anything until we
actually met like our anniversaries that
they that we met pretty much and that's
when we had our first kiss and that was
it's really nice it's something more
special when when you not saying you
should be like one of those virgins be
like they should really wait
you should really wait with Kish it's
really good but it's special else P
Nielson barrows I noticed that you take
care you care for charity actions and
stuff is this something that would
create educating your family or you
develop that for yourself um I think
it's thanks to you bros um you know it's
thanks to you bros and I can do shower
teas in the first place
if I was alone you know I could still
participate in other charities but I
couldn't work I don't think I could
organize in the same scale at least so
it's fast thanks to you bros and I think
it's really amazing so far last year we
I think it was like forty forty seven
thousand dollars towards charity that we
organized in ISM that we have donated in
total in this channel together with you
bros which is amazing
it's I think it's the coolest thing to
be to actually help out when I can and I
feel lucky to be where I am and I
people who are less lucky it it just
feels normal I guess what's your
favorite Nintendo game it's a donkey
kong country on the - Helena Morocco
what's your favorite song right now
making them way downtown walking fast
faces pass and I'm hold on
and I need you and I miss you and now I
wonder that would probably be some
[ __ ] gangster rap biggie or some 5050
sounds really cool
are you a duck yes Danny Danny Jones are
you a duck yes
Ariana Ellie are you a duck no clearly
people have been saying that you only
care about money
it's this true I think it's so stupid
that people actually think that I know
people are like oh he's lying he only
can like what have I done ever to make
it seem that I only care my money I
don't think I ever done anything to come
across as greedy on this channel and if
you actually watch this Fridays with
PewDiePie you know that I get I love
what I'm doing and I'm doing it because
I love doing it
um that's that's my only answer to it
unless that [ __ ] you want to go bowling
here why not had a monster whats your
favorite pokemon i prefer psychic
pokémon
I like Snorlax because he's fat and lazy
and I think that's a good example of
what you should be in life
alright Prez thank you for watching this
little Q&A sorry wasn't anything
spectacular or whatever I do I do want
to keep something special going on for
Friday with food pie so if you have any
suggestions on what I can do feel free
to comment and I will try to try to make
it happen you know other than that like
I said it's cool that we are
right now one of the biggest gaming
channels on YouTube like I said I I
don't feel like I deserve it I think I
almost try my best with what I do and
I'm happy that things have really gone
so well but I feel like come on now can
we just slow down a little bit because
it's just too much but I do really
appreciate it and most of all I
appreciate all of you bros for making it
possible for me to be doing what I'm
doing I'm living I'm living the dream
right now thanks to you bros and
building ii do was say thank you i
really do appreciate and by that they
were landis damn it hmm caramel activate